[Music]
quiet place is a film that I have very
fond memories of I was lucky enough to
get a very early screening for her and
the ending explained that I did on the
movie pretty much kick-started the
channel John Krasinski himself even
discussed my Deary on the film with one
of my friends who was doing interviews
on the press to her and I attribute a
lot of the channel's success to this
movie so when I saw that a quiet place
to would be announced I was very excited
to see exactly what the film would be
about and if the creative team behind it
first would still be involved whilst I
don't necessarily think that the movie
needs a sequel the more I thought about
it the more I realized that there are a
lot of potential avenues that the film
could go off into so what do we know
about the film itself well throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything that you need to know about a
quiet place to as well as giving my
theories on what the film's plot could
be there will be heavy spoilers here in
regards to the ending of the first movie
so if you haven't seen that then I
highly suggest that you turn off now but
without the way I'm definition and
welcome to the channel okay firstly
deadlines yesterday reported that the
film was in production and that John
Krasinski would once again be reprising
his role as the director this was
further confirmed by Krasinski who
posted an image of the farmhouse from
the film on Instagram with the caption
time to go back part 2 5 15 and 20
obviously from this we can summarize
that the film will be released on the
15th of May 2020 but what else can we
take from the tidbits that we've been
given well it Digital Spy in the last
couple of hours reported that bald
Krasinski and Emily Blunt will be
returning in their roles those who've
seen the first film will know that it
ends with Krasinski's characters
sacrificing himself to save his children
from the monsters that now inhabit the
world and that in the final few shots
Blunt and her daughter have figured out
a way to defeat them and are ready to
take them head-on so how exactly can
Krasinski played the character once more
if he's dead well personally I believe
that the film will take place over two
time periods a quiet place sort of
picked up in the middle
of the alien invasion and we were given
very little in terms of reasons as to
why the monsters now existed which led
to a lot of intrigue and speculation it
makes sense then for elements of the
film to showcase exactly what happened
when the aliens first landed and how
Krasinski Hamblin's characters had to
not only adjust to the blind creatures
that hunt unsound
but also how to adapt to the new world
this will clear up a lot of questions
circulating around the creatures origins
and would also lend a more human side to
the piece as the other time period will
probably be lacking it in the other time
period I think that it will pick up
immediately after blunt has just killed
her first monster and the others around
the area are rushing to the farm the
introduction will deal with her fighting
these off before her and her family have
to go to the other forms that were
hinted at in the first film due to the
family being heavily reliant on sign
language they will have to find other
ways to communicate with the survivors
who are not fluent in this this could
lead to scenarios where the other
survivors are unsure of glen's
characters and tensions and it would
heighten the drama we've seen in this
world that humans can be as dangerous as
the monsters if they panic and this
could easily create some intense
scenarios but in Krasinski in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly
around the release of a quiet place said
in regards to a sequel the idea of
seeing who these people were before this
all happened would be interesting but I
think actually it's now what's the next
chapter and what happens next I think
people feel very invested in this family
I think it's such an open book right now
and certainly for John who is lasering
into something as we speak so it's clear
that the creator's are unsure whether to
pick one time period or the other so it
makes the most sense for me to bounce
between the two obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the film and what
direction you think that it could go in
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my original
ending explained video on the film as
well as Krasinski's reaction to it which
will be linked at the end this is the
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
[Music]
[Music]